today we have a fascinating conversation
with professor pedro domingos
um remember if you like content like
this consider hitting the subscribe
button and rate us on apple podcasts by
the way um our friend pedro has written
this book called the master algorithm i
highly recommend you buy yourself a copy
it's absolutely fascinating um actually
i think we're going to consider making
some content on this book so if that's
something that interests you let us know
um yeah anyway enjoy the show
how are you sir
yo good how are you very good
we're good to see you again yeah good to
see you how's life yeah
life is good as much as possible in
these troubled times
yes i know exactly what you mean
right so um i'll tell you what um could
you just give us a quick piece on your
book the master algorithm
the master algorithm is in it's an
introduction to machine learning for a
broad audience
i decided to write it because i realized
that we were at the point where
everybody needs to know machine learning
not just the specialists
you know as a private citizen as a
decision maker you need to know not the
mechanical depths of how things work
but have a conceptual model of a machine
learning system is doing and so i wrote
a book covering the main styles of
machine learning and also what its main
um
consequences in the world today were at
the time and in the future the future
being now and a lot of that that i
talked about in the book is in progress
even in lesbian what i imagined so yeah
i'm curious about that so um
and not that i disagree at all why why
do you think it's important for kind of
like the general
the general population really to
understand machine learning and like
what do they need to understand about it
exactly as i said they don't need to
understand you know lbfts and stochastic
gradient descent
they uh you know here's an analogy that
i that i've often used
you don't need to know how the engine of
a car works
uh that's for the mechanics and the
mechanical engineers
but you do need to know how the steering
wheel and the pedals work
otherwise you're not going anywhere
and you know what machine learning today
is like a car that arrives at your door
and says i'll take you where you want
could i trust can i push back on that a
little bit we spoke to melanie mitchell
and she was talking about the four
fallacies and ai and you know things
like um
uh there was the first step fallacy so
you know assuming that we're on a
continuum to artificial general
intelligence and the lure of wistful
mnemonics was another one i think and
also that ai should actually be embodied
and you know just to push back on what
you said a little bit um well even
actually some people think that
statistics and artificial general
intelligence are somewhat synonymous
right so you kind of do need to know a
little bit what's going on right
no i mean look okay so let's dig down to
a slightly finer level right you need to
understand at different levels for
different things
right but there's even the most let's
just start at the most basic level
right
is that i saw a lot of people and i
still see including ceos making
decisions about machine learning that
are very costly because they haven't a
clue what machine learning is and and
you know related to that example
there's a whole
galaxy of misconceptions about machine
learning and ai more broadly with which
it's conflated these days of course
improperly which is confusing artificial
intelligence with human intelligence
and i want to you know i hope that you
know people who read the book
will gain a few things one of them is
that they will never have that
illusion again that ais like human
intelligence it may be right again i
cover that some some some many strains
in ar are come out of psychology and i
think that's good but fundamentally
to give you the technical definition
right ai is solving np complete problems
using heuristics
which is a very different notion from
what you see in the press and the people
talking about you know terminator and ai
bias and whatnot right there's this
expression that i really like which is
the homunculus fallacy i don't know if
you heard this the homunculus fallacy is
the fallacy that inside every ai system
there's a little man pulling these
dreams
it ain't like that and then for us it's
funny but for a lot of people it's that
they that's the metal mall that they
have because they've never been given a
better one right so you know to answer
your question more directly
think
so as as an individual right you need to
realize that you're interacting with
computer systems all the time that are
making decisions on your behalf that are
guided by machine learning
and and at that level you don't you know
you can even just have you know imagine
that all it's doing is logistic
regression or night base right
at that level it's enough there's
there's these attributes it's making
predictions about you based on
correlations between these attributes
this captures absolute machine learning
but is already you know important for
people to know but then as a
professional for example i think one of
the most important things that like your
use of machine learning as a
professional can go all the way from
being you know a hotshot machine
learning phd who knows all kinds of math
and logic and statistics and
optimization and whatnot to someone who
uses ai tools without knowing the ai
inside them
of course that's not ideal but in
between these two extremes of the
spectrum there's many different levels
of understanding for example you should
be able to build models this is
something that i've worked on a lot
because i think it's really important
like you should be able to build this is
what markov logic is for you should be
able to build models of your domain
whatever it is
combining data with all your expertise
without having to understand the gory
details of how machine learning works
you need the language in which you
express what you know and in which you
interact with the ai so you should be
able to teach that ai right
and you're right at this level you start
to need more than just use the steering
wheel and the pedals but you know you
have to start at the beginning
maybe you could clarify a bit from you
the audience the intended audience of
the book because i can certainly see
some segment of the population um
you know or expanding let's say the
population segment population that can
understand
some of those concepts but on the other
hand you know we have many
a long long history of of
lots of people misunderstanding very
basic
concepts like correlation is not
causation you know for example and
especially when you get into probability
theory you know there are prominent
examples of
of even mathematicians and certainly
scientists and and for example medical
medical doctors that
it's just not intuitive to get a lot of
the concepts in probability theory and
so
what about that i mean is the hope that
we can somehow break through that that
barrier or is it more you're targeting
let's say
uh say an engineer who needs to learn
something about machine learning in
order to like you're saying
build models that can help them at work
i'm actually targeting all of the above
and in fact
i think a lot of the art of writing a
book for a general audience
and i really looked into this with
examples from you know positive and
negative examples of this you know
before i wrote the book you
if you can at all you should try to
write a book that works at multiple
levels
someone should be able to read the book
superficially and many people have and
and get something out of it
but that was definitely not just what i
was shooting for i was actually very
determined to actually have a serious
coverage of essentially all of machine
learning at a certain level of
abstraction of course but like you got
to come out of that book again one of my
pet peeves has been that like people
learn type a or machine learning this
does it's deep learning but it could be
kernel machines or you know invasion
learning or whatever you know in school
and because they were taught randomly by
the people who were of that persuasion
and then they think that's all there is
and then they go through their life
applying their hammer to everything that
now of course looks like a nail and
that's that's very costly right so
i also want to you know if you i mean if
if i had to say like at the end of the
day who are the people who most most
enjoyed
the book
they were actually people who have some
technical background
but are from other fields
right because there's like you know
there's a lot of you know real math and
engineering and stuff in science in that
book kind of like stated in a way that's
accessible but if you know that you
actually you know you you feel it and
you like seeing the connections made and
and again i you know i said that in the
introduction to the book even if you're
a machine learning pro
i hope that you will learn a lot of
things from this book yeah and then i
think a lot of people have now who are
the people who have most benefited from
reading the book i think it's like
you know it's the ceo
you know like there was this book that i
think george miller wrote many years ago
called physics for future presidents
it's like you know if you're going to be
the president of the united states you
don't need the phd in physics but you
even in charge of a nuclear arsenal and
blah blah so you know there's some
things that maybe you ought to know and
you know like one of my you know cluster
of you know
clusters of audiences for the book was
like the ceos and indeed i mean i know
countless ceos who really like the book
right and have told me so because they
needed they needed to catch up on
machine learning like badly and this
they're not going to read the textbook
so it was a godsend for them you know
just to give you an example jensen
hawaii right the ceo of nvidia right
this happened at the time that he was
pivoting you know from gaming to ai he
told everybody at the company to read
the book period
and they did it
you know indeed
for coming up to me so i'm like oh you
know i read this and i like this and i
have this question so you know these are
all parts of the audience for the book
could i pick you up on on a couple of
things so i'm i'm very interested in um
you know i said about melanie mitchell's
lure of wishful mnemonics and
anthropomorphization because i think you
you resent the anthropomorphization of
these machine learning algorithms and
your recent paper actually kind of
showed that there was a a kind of an
analogy between many of these machine
learning algorithms and that's why i
want to take a step back because you
could see
many of the empirical and statistical
approaches to ai as being somewhat
analogous and there are some very
divergent conceptions of what ai is you
know we spoke about the um
embodiment for example but psychologists
separate the mind from the brain and
there are emergentists for example
do you think there's any value in
conceptualizer i mean sorry just to go
back to the beginning um we you were
saying that people didn't really have
any deep understanding of what's going
on but the level of abstraction is
important your frame of reference to
understand this is important right
well i mean
you said the word there that kind of
print my ears it's not that there's an
analogy between these different
approaches
it's much deeper than that right
the paper that you just referred to it's
actually showing that every model
learned by gradient descent is a kernel
machine so maybe at the end of the day
all the machine learning that we've been
doing prominently including deep
learning is just kernel machines so as
much as i want people to learn the full
spectrum
the you know the variety of machine
learning algorithms i don't want it to
be a collection of stamps
that's not good science and in fact the
story of the book right is that there's
the five types of machine learning you
know the bayesians the connectionists
the symbolists etc and and then we visit
them and learn their way of doing things
in their wisdom but then
the goal of this whole process is to
find the master algorithm right and
there's a chapter in the book where we
put these things together and there is a
master algorithm and in fact that
chapter has held up very well and this
paper they just talked about is another
step in that direction so i think when
all is said and done right we we do you
know um
machine learning is not a hammer
and it's better to have a swiss army
knife right but a swiss army knife is
still five tools jammed into one right i
think i think what we're gonna
understand is that at some deeper level
all these things are really just you
know variations on the same
theme right think of different regimes
of the same equation but right that's
that's i think we're gonna on that
though if we spoke to a symbolist they
would say yeah all of those machine
learning algorithms are the same
and um if we spoke to an emergentist
that would be a completely i mean we
spoke to ben gertzel for example he's a
great example of an emergentist and also
jeff hawkins as well but no there there
are some completely different frames of
reference here and you could you could
quite easily just conflate all of the
machine learning empirical approaches
and just say they're all different sides
of the same coin right
well i mean so
this is what i love about it is that so
first of all
there are people who don't believe in
this idea right
you know the quick essential example is
is marvin minsky right
marvin is his whole theory of mind is
that it's one damn thing after another
there is no unified to you the mind
right i mean i don't need to read the
society of mine but it's literally 200
chapters it's about you know one of 200
different things right and and i
understand that but you know so there's
so there's these people for whom you
know what i say the master algorithm in
that chapter doesn't make sense right
and i respect their opinion but the the
fun part is that of the people who do
believe in the master algorithm and
actually think that deep down almost all
machine learning people believe in it
because you know like the point of
machine learning and this is how i start
the book right is to have algorithms
that can learn anything that's the magic
of it it's like it's a general algorithm
it's like the master key that's where
the name comes from that opens all locks
right but then the thing that's kind of
like hilarious almost to me is that like
the the hardest core believers in any in
every one of these schools and you know
rich sutton with reinforcement learning
and jeff harkins with this theory they
do believe that all algorithms are the
same namely theirs
that's right part of what they explain
the book is like no no no it doesn't
work right i say that like there's these
five major problems in in machine
learning that in ai that you have to
solve
and these different algorithms are very
good for solving different ones for
example the symbolists are the ones who
can learn composable knowledge you know
back props talks great assignment but
you know what you got to realize and i
give examples this in domains like you
know robotics and fighting cancer and
whatnot like you have to solve all five
because if all you have is back prop
you're deluding yourself that backdrop
is gonna you know i have this ongoing
argument with jan lacoon where he says
that like you know ai is going to be
solved by greater descent it's already
descent you know you either do grid
intercept or written free optimization
and rated free optimization is so plus
inefficient so ergo you know ai is going
to be solved by goodness sake which too
much just sounds i mean
i i really respect yeah and you know i
agree with him on a lot of things but on
this one i just can't fathom his blind
fate in backdrops so there's a lot of
this in in ai and the book is definitely
confronting that yeah i mean we're so
interested in open-endedness and we love
kenneth stanley and he gave some
examples of um some you know open-ended
algorithms that beat
gradient-based reinforcement learning
agents and because a lot of people say
well evolutionary algorithms are rubbish
right because they're not principled you
have this random mutation and it's not
principled but
demonstrably i mean yeah
well the dictionary algorithms right i
have a chapter in the so they're one of
the tribes right the the evolutionaries
and and many people in machine learning
when they saw the book said like oh why
do you have a chapter about this nobody
does it anymore it's not machine
learning i'm like there's a whole big
conference dedicated to this and they're
growing as well and and i mean it's not
in principle right again you can debate
the ins and outs of this but i do
believe there's a lot to come from
looking at that i think the problem is
that we do not understand evolution well
enough yet
right we have a cartoon of evolution
exactly and that's why we're not making
it better but we need to work with
evolutionary biologists and the people
of the evolutionary gamete and all that
and i think very important things will
come out of that same on the
optimization side and like you know we
do not understand the brain well enough
and you know when we do we'll think that
the idea that the brain learns by green
descent is a joke
i mean like the only part of the brain
that even remotely looks like it could
be run by backdrop is the cerebellum
right
there is a certain similarity between
the cerebellum and and you know and
backdrop not the cortexes jeff hawkins
will tell you or probably told you in
great detail but even there right the
most notable thing about the cerebellum
which is for learning mainly motor
skills is that
once you learn a skill you never lose it
again right you learn to ride a bike
when you're six and it's with you
forever even if you don't ride the bike
for four years contrast that with the
catastrophic forgetting that is the
signature problem of backpop so you know
we're very far from understanding how
these things work so we need to
understand them better and then we need
to you know bring those ideas to ai as
we have very successful in the past and
also i think those fields would benefit
from the ideas that we come up with in
ai right you know i like psychology i
like evolution and whatnot but at the
end of the day it's so much more
satisfying to be an ai researcher
because you get to make progress so much
faster with computers than than with
doing experiments with people or you
know or things like that i know there
are so many fascinating um things that
pick up on that jeff hawkins is looking
into before before we leave that topic i
wanted to bring up something
specifically about learning from the uh
the brain i wonder if you're familiar
with um
uh blake richards
at all in his in his work about you know
the neocortical sort of microcircuits
and and pyramidal you know neurons and
what was interesting about a
presentation i saw him give is
is he was asking the question okay we
pretty much know the brain can't
implement gradient descent you know
biologically the way it is but what they
figured out is that it appears to
implement something that's like a
stochastic kind of you know
version of of gradient descent and i
think exactly what what you're pointing
out here is that we can learn a lot from
that you know so there are some there
are some ways in which that stochastic
sort of gradient descent can actually
outperform gradient descent and they're
doing experiments on that and it's worth
at least exploring right like what the
biology is doing
i mean it's definitely exploring and i
sympathize but um i mean first of all
stochastic gradient set is what
everybody uses for everything no but no
i'm not talking about it yeah it's it's
different i mean i understand but like
my um
feeling about
the work of people like blake richards
is that
they are trying too hard
to make
the brain fit
what we think is learning coming from an
ml point of view right i've seen this
you know happened you know it's like
people
the brain is so complex that it manages
to look like anything we want it to look
like
and people you know joshua benji is
another example right like they've come
up with with many ways of trying to say
like well but this is how the brain
really does back prop
my feeling and it's just the feeling is
that the brain just doesn't do back prop
it does predictive coding predictive
coding i think is a very important idea
and you know if i had to guess looking
forward you know when we understand how
the cortex learns it will be predictive
coding again our understanding
predictive coding is an old idea in fact
there's a lot of new confirmation of
predictive coding coming out of the
neuroscience which i think is very
exciting
not enough to change the the other
problem is that the neuroscience under
constrains the algorithms
we don't know enough to decide what your
algorithm is going to be right so that
it's a very
you know a leaky interface between the
two sides but if i had to which doesn't
mean it's not worth it but at the end of
the neurosciences like at this point
does not so much constrain you has maybe
give you inspirations and i think to my
intuition predictive coding is actually
how we really learn and again what we do
is we do predictive coding and then we
remember you know in machine learning we
have this unfortunate decision between
memory and learning and actually
remember things are overfitting but
again if you if you go back to this
notion of like that we talked about
about you know a greater descent
learning kernel machines right what it's
really doing is remembering the examples
except very efficiently in a superposed
way right i think this combination of
predictive coding and superposition my
guess is this this is it this is not the
whole story but this is really a core
part of how the brain learns now
you can take any function right
and
that i'm optimizing right and as long as
it's continuous and say that well you
know uh this is
take whatever differentials the equi
equation your system obeys and you say
like oh you know this is great that
descent on something right
now you can always you know if you have
a function you can always think about
it's integral it's derivative right the
question is is that helpful
sometimes it's helpful sometimes it's
not and again my feeling
i can't prove this but i mean there's a
lot of work that i think is pointing in
this direction is that
don't think about gradient descent
that's actually the wrong way to think
about it think about the differential
equation that your system is following
right it's it's descending the gradient
of the loss right but it's a
differential equation right and the fact
that that was the gradient of something
is actually secondary another question
that we should be asking is like why is
this the differential equation that you
know an intelligent brain uses i think
the real difference of the equation is
going to be even staying in you know
continuous land which you can right is
going to be something much more
interesting
and i don't think it's going to be
anything humongously complex it's going
to be more complex than greater descent
but it's going to have a much more
interesting and more powerful dynamics
to think about is that like as a
dynamics for learning green descent is
kind of very limited in fact i you know
i said this thing to yan on twitter not
too young i said this thing on twitter
that yen then replied to uh
a little defensively and it was just
this people who believe that
intelligence will be solved you know by
greater descent need to explain how
scientists do scientific discovery using
nothing but gradient descent
right and i mean i
i think this sentence alone makes it
obvious that that it's not all just
greater descent right like they're not
even using greater descent let alone
it's celebrated to sin right could i um
ask you a little bit about that so um
we're speaking with numenta by the way
and they've really leaned into sparsity
and we've spoken to jonathan frankel the
lottery lottery ticket hypothesis and
you know for neural networks to use
gradient descent gradient descent has to
work right so it turns out gradient
descent works much better
on dense mlps and actually most of the
architectural tweaks in neural networks
are to make the optimization more
amenable to gradient descent but
sparsity is interesting isn't it because
the representation is much more robust
when you specify the network because you
kind of tell it to forget about all of
the low frequency instances um so are we
in a bit of a catch-22 where we can't
train the things you know
um into a sparse network directly
well so um
i mean i agree with you so great
interesting works right and i have
nothing against grading i use it myself
all the time right and i've even written
papers too unlike you know proving great
descent for certain you know
representations like some product
networks that that we've developed and
whatnot but but you're right the thing
is that
a lot of the work people do today is
shoehorning everything
to make life possible for greater
descent
and this at the end of the day is
actually very harmful
right we are real i mean i think when
people look back 20 years from now if
they even bother to they're going to be
horrified at
these byzantine concoctions
of learning these you know bazillions of
parameters 99.9 of which were redundant
right but why do we need them because we
need them to make life easy for waiting
to set right now sparsity is a very
important idea for many reasons one of
them is that
energy consumption is the number one
constraint on what the brain does
your brain even at rest consumes a
quarter of your energy
right this is mind-boggling right yes in
fact
apparently you know you know cows have
much more powerful digestive systems
than humans have and but we have to give
up on that in order to free up energy
for the parade so you know we have a
different ecological niche right but the
point is that like energy consumption is
is really really a strong constraint and
we forgot that during the first 50 years
of ai now it's coming back for different
reasons because of data centers and and
mobile and whatnot but but sparsity i
mean if you talk you know like when i
talk to jeff dean one of the things that
he's always saying is that like we need
sparser networks i'm like what is your
wish list the number one is we don't
want this whole network to be on at the
same time right we want just a small
amount and which is what happens with
your prey right
most of your brain isn't on most of the
time and same with the connections right
so so i think there's a lot to be done
there now to me the most
ironic part of all of this is that
people now forget
that you know deep learning the modern
age of deep learning starting sick at
two thousand and you know two three
had three phases
the first phase was was the you know the
the the pre-training right i remember
when jeff was you know this was the
thing right
and that you know that did some things
like you know it was good for speech and
whatnot but then there was a phase that
no lies forgotten that was all about
sparsity
it was sparse coding all the way
i remember talking with andrew inc you
know well like maybe the second deep
learning workshop when there were only
50 of us
it's kind of
you know hard to remember that now but
we all fit in a room with the forces
around it
and then you was very gung-ho right and
he said like at the panel at the end
something like um i don't want to put
words in his mouth but like you know
we're going to solve a.i now in no time
right i'm exaggerating a little bit but
that was the spirit of what he was
saying and and then at the end of it you
know i asked him you know ryan was like
so wow you know tell me how how are we
about to solve a yeah and you know what
his answer was lit i think he would be
embarrassed to hear this now but like
his answer was
well we now know how v1 works
v1 is sparse coding
and all the brain uses the same
algorithm therefore we know how the
brain works that's kind of like the uh
the thousand brains perspective um yeah
i mean he was influenced by jeff hawkins
i don't know if you know
quoted him in the show he said that jeff
convinced him in his first book on
intelligence that um human level general
intelligence could be explained by a
single learning algorithm
indeed right like and in fact the master
algorithm's first working title was the
one algorithm right so we're really all
in the same wavelength here but my point
was that there was a point at which
sparsity was the
deep learning thing and then and then of
course lxnet happened and we're in the
age of alexnet still right where on the
contrary we learn these massively dense
redundant over parameterized things
because we got we got you piece to learn
them right i mean
gpus in a way are like this joker in the
deck of ai that scrambled everything
right i mean gpus just gave an unfair
advantage to a particular set of
techniques
right right yeah
the machine the machine lottery but just
a closer loop on that these models are
not trainable without um starting from a
dense model as far as i'm aware even the
specification algorithms usually they
they start with a dense model and then
they prune and prune and prune
sgd just doesn't seem to work without a
dense model
no no no well so there's a there's a
couple different things here um
you have to distinguish sparsity at
learning time with sparsely at
performance time
google for example really cares about
sparsity at performance time because
they pay the electricity bill seriously
right if you need i mean like i i had if
i had to guess like uh and it's not
completely i guess
uh
the great majority of google's entire
electricity bill these days consists of
running deep learning albums
one month right
right their electricity bill is all
those redundant connections right so yes
you can it's the same thing with with
with uh with you know systems on the
edge right which are very popular like
like no google has you know the latest
you know android phones have to have
tpus in them
this is how far we've gotten right and
you know like and a colleague of mine
just sold his company to apple uh and
what it does is it sparsifies networks
down to like you know one bit per weight
and then they still this little they
work a little bit worse but still well
enough right so right this kind of
performance time sparse is very
important right now you're talking about
learning times person right learning
times faster is not as important and the
thing there is that
if you follow that again there's
learning inspired by the brain and
there's the connections paradigm
which is actually very impoverished
version of learning by the the
connections paradigm is like your
structure learning is learned there is
no structure learning therefore you have
to start out with a redundant structure
because that's all you can do
and now if you ask the symbol list
they'll they'll pull their head out this
because like we can do discrete search
we don't need to do that right we can we
can we can do architecture search and
again i do that all the time as well and
it's ridiculous not to but it's again
there's this i don't want to say
ideological but there's like what i've
noticed is that the deep learning people
don't like the idea of learning
structure it's like it doesn't agree
with them because they have this like
the brain and then you talk to
evolutionaries and then like
that you're just tuning parameters the
real learning is discovering the
structure of the brain so structure
learning in my view is an essential part
of the master algorithm and then you
know you can be as far as you wanted
learning time in fact when you learn a
vision network you know or or the rule
of set a set of
rules typically you start out from zero
the null model right so why not do that
there's nothing wrong with doing that
well because you can't if you don't
invent the structure yourself you can't
give it a cool name like horseshoe or
you know something like that it has a
nice
symmetric shape but i want to come back
to um your predictive coding
point which is that
bingio joshua benjio has has frequently
been talking about the importance of
simulating like the world models and for
example we've been looking at his um
g flow net uh paper lately which which
also hits upon the energy thing you know
how can i simulate possible worlds
efficiently um and and with some tricks
you know to make it better than just say
mcmc i'm wondering if you can talk some
about one the connection between
predictive coding and really the
simulation of world models as a as a
core component of um of learning really
and at least the way humans do it and
also any comments you have on uh on
bingio's um recent work
so yeah so i definitely believe
at a certain level at least in this idea
of stimulating the world
and it's inextricably tied with
predictive coding right predictive
coding is you have a model of the world
you predict using it and then it's the
errors that are the signal that gets
propagated
among other things this is very
efficient energetically because it means
and again there are decades of
psychology saying that like what you
know what your brain is do it actually
starts at the retina it's like you're
just throwing out all the information
that you can throw out
right and you can throw it out because
you have a model of the world in fact
the whole point of memory and
intelligence always is to have that
model of the world right and if you talk
to gary marcus he's always pounding on
model of the world if you talk to jan
lukkun he's always talking about model
of the world right let's take maybe an
even better example if you look at what
joshua's group has been doing right for
a long time is this whole idea that like
you know i generate the model of the
world and then you know and that that's
what i use for everything and then you
know comparing it with predictions that
so at some level i completely agree with
this idea okay but now i think
uh in many ways the ways that different
people have been pursuing this including
yahshua and josh and what not
i'm a little queasy about them because
again come back to the human brain right
and having a big complicated model of
the world is is a very costly thing
right so this idea that what you have
is a generative model of the world
right
you know once upon a time i believe the
injury there's a lot of people who say
and i think josh is one of those and and
jeff hitman too in a strange way right
they they all believe in generative laws
right maybe what jeff thinks in the
joshua vision called generative models
and what you really call it there's
there's some overloading of vocabulary
going on here like but what is the
generative model you know at least in a
formal sense it's a probability
distribution of how the world generates
today like if you're a beijing right and
you know josh is of asian right these
days he plays a deep learning person on
tv but you know deep down he's very much
of asian right is you have a probability
distribution from which you generate you
know can generate samples then you can
also update that with the data and you
know and then you get your poster and
whatnot right and the problem this is a
very attractive idea
right and i've had arguments with
prominent people in machine learning
less so these days because of deep
learning where they say like you either
doing generative learning what you're
doing is on principle
discriminative learning is on principle
discriminative learning is a hack
directive learning is what's real right
and and i understand you know when
people are influenced by physics and
what not that that's how they think but
this is wrong well can i come in on that
because this is very this is very
analogous to you know we were saying
before with evolutionary algorithms oh
it's unprincipled so with josh tanenbaum
let's say dreamcoded because i know he's
done some bayesian stuff as well but
that's very much a neural guy did
discrete program search and and you
could argue that you know it's a
factorial search space but apparently
this neural network makes it a linear
search space but seems seems a little
bit dodgy doesn't it but um what
hinton's doing is he's got this neural
network that models instinct so with
alphago we actually did this alpha as
well as monte carlo tree search and that
really is system two right i mean first
of all it's a bit weird that we're
modeling it as discrete actions you're
talking about the brain a minute ago and
it seems a bit muddled in my mind to
talk about predictive coding and then
talk about traversing
you know discrete actions but let's
stick with the actions now hinton
doesn't say
hinton doesn't say that this is
reasoning or system two he thinks that
instinct is something completely
different but it's it still should be
modeled with a neural network
no but okay
we bring in a different set of issues
here uh i don't know if you've heard you
know danny kahneman's diatribe against
people like benjamin talking about
system one tell me i'd love to know
yeah he's like what these people are
calling
he says they you know again not to put
words in his lot but he says they're
completely confused right
what a lot of disney plenty of people
let me call system on system two isn't
right
you like they they so so the cartoon and
this is a powerful cartoon in our
community is that and i mean you've
heard this many times is that
system one is perception
and system two is reasoning
and deep networks are good at
and we've like we've mastered system one
we got deep learning system one we got
that down right
but now right to achieve full
intelligence we need models of the world
and reasoning and all of that and that
system too so now we got to do that as
well
and then he kind of looked at this and
says like no that's not what i meant
the model of the world is system one you
guys haven't even remotely figured
system what to begin with
system one is everything you do
automatically
again i oversimplify but this is a
better approximation like system one is
everything you do automatically think of
everything you do automatically it's
very in fact it's because you have a
model of the world
encoded in your neurons that you can do
so many powerful things automatically
and then when that doesn't and system
one is with what we do every moment you
know of the day when that doesn't work
then you get into this slower harder
search process
that we call conscious reasoning
and that's what system two is so
like you know we we haven't figured out
system one yet
i wish we had but that's actually the
bigger challenge right is there like i
mean in many ways you could say that the
criticism of symbolic ai is that like
you're trying to build a system too
without a system one under under it and
that's not going to work and now to get
to this question of alpha go an instinct
what alpha guy does i think is extremely
interesting in a way that most people
haven't noticed and that i think is
actually quite related to the psychology
into this question of instinct versus
search right is that like
people make this distinction between the
discrete search and the continuous
behavior that is actually not there
right like your instinctive behavior is
just you're compiled explicitly behavior
after doing it many times again there's
a host of psychology literature that
shows this right there's a few instincts
that you are born with but that's all
we're talking about is like you know
like the chess grand master's ability to
look at a board then in the tenth of the
section make a move that defeats you
after you're thinking about it for 15
minutes
what they're doing is actually not
fundamentally different
from a computational point of view
they're doing the same process that it's
all compiled
into their neurons which is what alphago
is doing right so it's like what it's
actually doing is like it's compiling
this you know monte carlo research
into the value of the neural network
right
and this is good because then then that
so so what you do is like you do it's
you know here's a imperfect analogy but
we want to have like you're compiling
macros
what the neural network has is search
macros
and that's what instinct is a lot of is
like these macros that you've acquired
you had you made all those mistakes many
times and now you have learned to
instinctively not make them because you
know that's going to lead in a bad
direction so there really is you know
intelligence is very confusing in that
regard because it's so plastic but a lot
of this a lot of this distinction
between system one does this and system
two does that they're actually doing the
same thing they're just doing on
different time frames that's right so
time time is really the the key element
i think at least from what i've seen and
so what's wrong with
if i think of system one is
any calculation that you can do
in a single forward pass and like some
relatively small number of
of layers whereas system two is
is something you can do computationally
like say on a turing machine given more
time iteratively is that like kind of an
okay breakdown
it's
not quite i mean i sympathize but here's
the thing is is um you can paralyze
right to take that i mean
the turing machine covers both of those
right and the tuning machine is a
sequential process but i can say i'm
going to start paralyzing and that's a
lot of what your brain is that it's
massively parallelism number one but
number two there's the role of learning
right
what learning is doing is like i mean
think of proving a theorem right it's
like it's a quintessential symbolic
reasoning task right it's the series of
discrete steps and there's a very large
search base like you know which axiom
which inference rule do i apply now but
what a good mathematician has is that
that's not how their brain works they
have all these structures compiled into
their brain and all these analogies like
they look at the form of something like
oh this is like that form that i saw
before and if i tweak this right this is
what you do right so the same the exact
same thing that can be done sequentially
can be done you know in parallel but not
without exponential blow up right it's
like sure you can you can take an
iterative circuit and you can splay it
out as a forward pass but you get an
exponential blow up in terms of
in terms of circuitry and as you brought
up earlier biology is going to optimize
like energetically to
avoid that the exponential blow up is
with you in one form or the other so
there's a certain envelope of time and
space that you can't get out of now you
can and the brain does do that in the
supporting ai make trade-offs between
spending more time and spending more
space
and sometimes reducing one exponential
blows up the other but let's you know
but the problem the real problem for us
is actually those is like we we will
take anything
right
right we if we can do anything in our
installation in any way we will but the
problem is that you don't make a blow up
go away a fundamental blow up if you
will you know if you didn't do things
right you can but you don't make a
fundamental blob go away by by shifting
from space to time off from time to
space the blob is you know is always
going to be there
why exactly is the alphago configuration
not learning
so having a discrete tree search over a
policy i mean does that imply that josh
tannenbaum stuff is not learning
remember how kasparov was beaten there
was no learning involved
right and there didn't need to be
right i'm not i'm not sure i follow you
it was there was there was plenty of
learning that went into the construction
of deep blue
no i mean so we're talking about this
brother no no no no there was no machine
learning well sorry can can you because
it seems like a dichotomy you know
searching and learning
can can you explain the continuum
between that dichotomy
yes so uh
you know playing games is a good example
right so
i teach students in a class to play
games with no learning
right and most of your you know pc you
know just playing programs that's what
they do right they do zero learning
right meaning their state when they play
the next game is is the same as when
they play the previous game and what
they do is they search for moves
right
this is interest this is reasoning right
this again is supposedly what this is
what we feel ourselves doing explicitly
when we play chess is like oh if i move
my pawn here will you move your rook
there or will he do this with your queen
right that's the street search okay so
you're saying some kind of model or
characterization of the problem
which you can optimize against that's
learning
it doesn't have to be model it's like
this there's a search space right
there's a set of all possible states of
the board right some states of the board
are wins for me i want to reach one of
those okay and i have my initial states
and i have my operators which are the
moves that i could make and now my
choice is just the discrete choice of
operators this is a this is a discrete
problem by nature right you can't
pretend it's continuous you can embed it
in continuous like it's a discrete
problem because you have the squid
sensor choices which is like which moves
do i make where do i put my piece on the
board and go to the center right and now
the problem right is that there's an is
the exponential block that we were just
talking about if there wasn't the next
dimension blow up right you know as in
tic-tac-toe you know it's too small
right you could just have a table that
tells you how to play right so in a way
the whole the whole ai is all about
where the table gets too large right
yeah
discrete problems are learnable though
right so so it's not the discreteness
that's that's of concern here
well but again there's two parts here in
every learning system there's the
learning component and there's the
performance component
right the performance component is
driving the car it's playing the game
it's the thing that actually does the
task that you want the performance
component is what we do when we write
programs right and in the classic ki
again playing system the performance
component is doing a search over moves
right
now machine learning
is actually in a way all of learning is
a meta search
what it's doing is creating a
performance components
right you have a search over performance
components
over what networks to have or what sets
of rules to have over what heuristics
are traditionally in game playing and
naturally in in a way still in in in
alphago the main place where the machine
learning comes in is in evaluating the
board for how good it looks
right and this is you know the
traditional airway to solve this
research problems is with heuristics
and the heuristic is saying like oh this
moves looks you know you rate the move
as to how good it looks right and
there's this tradition was like peace
advantage controlled at the center and
arthur samuels you know
when he coined the term machine learning
it was with the checkers playing program
and what he was learning
was very ahead of his time right by
myself play just like mine was the
weights all these different factors in
the evaluation function right so he had
the whole performance system that did
search that blah blah and there was one
thing that was being learned which was
the weight of you know control of the
center versus piece of advantage versus
something else right now of course these
days you can learn every part of this
but the learning can be continuous while
the performance system is discrete and
definitely the learning and the
performance system are very different
again this is another confusion that i
think b devils a lot of discussions of
machine learning and ai is that people
conflate
the machine learning algorithm with the
learned model
right
that's why different things they are
just completely different things that we
we're guilty because you know we call a
classifier a system that learns a
classifier right so we we have fostered
that confusion right which was okay when
it was you know 500 of us you know in an
obscure field but not anymore right so
we've got to make that distinction
between the learning component and the
performance component and either of them
could be discrete or continuous and and
both of them in ai
usually involve a search but they
searches over different things
so so the monte carlo research that is
like multicultural research is just your
quintessential classic symbolic ai
inference process search process right
which you could do with no learning
whatsoever but of course what makes it
powerful is that there's a neural
network that is there's really sucking
up the result of doing a lot of this
search so that you don't have to do it
anymore you can do it in one step and
this to me sounds a lot like what
psychology shows us the human brain as
again back to the discriminative models
you know versus uh generative and kind
of the conversation around g flow net
and where you said
a lot of people maybe are going wrong in
the direction is thinking that the model
needs to be
complex enough and accurate enough to
generate real world
examples where it doesn't necessarily
need to be able to do that it just needs
to be able to discriminate but but on
the other hand i think there is this
this notion that the brain is doing this
kind of simulation so i at least know i
do that i game out scenarios what if
this happens that happens so what's
producing those those um samples or
those possible world world models and if
you could just talk more about this
distinction and and what you think of
say g flow nuts or similar
yeah this is absolutely exactly the this
is a crucial question in in in my view
and here's the thing is that
if you can have a generative model of
the world that's accurate
you're in great shape
right but the problem is that and the
problem with the capital p is that a
full generative model of the world is
just impossibly costly
in memory in energy in inference time is
just infeasible
so you can you know stab your foot and
say like you got to be principal but
you'll die while everything else
survives
we gotta and the idea of discriminative
learning and i mean i totally understand
where this comes from and i used to kind
of like sympathize with this back when i
was a grad student and then i learned
better right is that
in a way discriminate a lot of people
you know even in science right machine
learning is now you know penetrating
every science and there's like often
this like you know reaction of dislike
because you know machine learning is
like this oh you gather a bunch of
features and then you do greatness on
them and you hack and you hack in your
back and then i do better than the
scientists and the scientists get really
frustrated with this because it's like
you're just hacking you don't have any
fundamental understanding of the process
that generates this data the phenomenon
the genetic model right the way we and
then they think this is all that machine
learning is and then i thought well no
there's this part of machine learning
that deals with generative models and
blah blah blah and then and then they
start to smile and they start to get
closer to nirvana right so i understand
like that the scientific impulse to a
lot of things properly as opposed to
just hack a bunch of thought right but
here's the thing
you know we are a part of evolution and
and and and our artifacts are we also
doing evolution right
and in evolution the supreme rule of the
universe is whatever works
and you know a fly has a discriminative
model of the world because that's all it
needs
putting a generative model of the world
on a flight would be stupid that fly
would die
and the others would live
now where this right so and the same
thing in a.r like we had 50 years of low
progress in ai until people in machine
learning said what we're going to do is
settle this aside and start learning on
real data from day one
and we're going to measure accuracy on
real data right and that led to a lot of
hacking but those that also that's where
we are today now you know now we come to
your question so this is why in some
sense discriminative learning is
actually better founded more more
fundamental than generative learning
right but now we come to very important
questions like what about the simulation
that i'm doing and you're doing that we
all know we do and it's so powerful and
and and predictive coding requires right
so i think that what happens is that as
your brain gets more powerful
and you have a more powerful sensorium
because your ecological niche you know
calls for it say humans like once you
have more powerful vision and a wider
range of behaviors that blah blah blah
then you're and i
i've also observed this happening in my
own research in ai which kind of you
know is interesting right a lot of
people like the new discriminative
models start to get more and more
powerful more and more flexible and and
you start to discover more and more
general things so a generative model is
some is what a descriptive model evolves
into
once it gets sufficiently powerful and
flexible right you want to start to
detect these invariants another very
important idea and as you detect more
and more invariance you start to have
something that's more more like genetic
model but now at the end of the day what
you have in your brain and what you're
having predictive coding
we have this illusion that it's complete
generative model of the world but it
isn't
right
well look at some things where you just
learn and apply the things that you need
to in order to guide your action
predictive coding does not exist for its
own sake it exists to guide your action
so any part of your sensor of the
world's model that's not needed to guide
your action goes out because it's
wasting the energy and making you less
fit i i appreciate that you said that um
generative models are very costly but
there are many folks in the space i mean
like max welling for example that that
really say we need to have generative
models but thing is we know i don't know
um whether you saw our latest episode
with lacoon but uh randall ballastrio
had this spline theory of neural
networks which basically says that
neural networks don't extrapolate in the
sense of continuing the pattern they
kind of are interpolators so presumably
these generative models are very
convergent they don't really um
extrapolate outside of the training
distribution but just to finish this
point so um what we really need to have
if we are using our imagination is
genuine extrapolation and i think what
bengio's doing with this g flow nets is
rather than picking the most likely
reward trajectory he's kind of
deliberately um disadvantaging it on
average by you know kind of allowing it
to sample um lower likelihood but higher
entropy um you know trajectories that
would give you more information gain but
there's something really fundamental
there isn't there about being able to
explore um the unknown not just the
things that we know about
i mean absolutely so there's a couple of
points here one is that
i'm not arguing against genetic models
if you notice right i'm arguing against
properly understanding how they emerge
and what their role is
we shouldn't be prematurely trying to
learn generative models in situations
where they don't make sense at the end
of the day your brain does have a very
powerful gender to model the world right
it is it is able to generate you know
dreams and and like it's able to
generate you know the features that it
then you know compares with the world by
by predictive coding so
i you know i
again i'm not arguing against model
modeling i'm marking against
understanding it properly and doing it
properly now what does that mean right
and and
this is where this so
what a lot of people i think including
yoshi are trying to do is actually what
what predictive coding does better right
actually you know this goes back to
practical which is like
predictive coding
again to paint the cartoon is like this
your sensory data is coming into your
thalamus right from your retina via the
optic nerve and whatnot and what
predictive coding is doing is comparing
not just one candidate model
but a whole bunch of them
in fact my view is that it's actually
very cleverly and efficiently comparing
an exponential number of models we could
go into the details of that but it's
it's effectively in non-exponential time
in linear time uh you know this is where
it is from some prime networks and so on
coming it's comparing a whole bunch of
models at the same time
and seeing which one wins
and you know like this is a constant
thing like you know the work of the deep
learning people particularly work that
tries to be more profitable like you
know like the energy models and the
contrasting divergence and like this is
always because like
in order to generalize properly i also
need to know what it is that does not
hold
and then they go into all this like you
know
things that are so painful like you know
monte carlo this and like i mean and you
will get another i don't know decades of
that right and it's like you don't need
to do that you you what you need is like
you know if you have this process of
comparing you know even doesn't have to
be exponential but exponential is
actually very useful
comparing like you know you're 100 best
models not random not small artificial
you know digressions from the truth you
know i could get max welding also has i
mean and all this work is interesting
but i think it's kind of like doing
something in a more difficult way than
is necessarily i mean there's this very
silly fact about the brain right that
like
all our models are feet forward but in
fact the feedback connections outnumber
them by an order of magnitude
i don't know if you know this there's 10
times more connections going back
than forward
right it's not just that we're not
capturing what my god we're not
capturing 10 percent of what's going on
and one theory of this which i don't
know if it's super really resolution is
like what are those feedback connections
they're precisely all those models
right your brain has all these models
and you you know fit for this one
reality
you know and the errors in that reality
like because this is a very you know
clever multi-level process like you're
only propagating the errors right if
your simplest model quickest model of
the world explains that it perfectly it
stops there right and you have you know
a reaction that doesn't even go to your
cortex right but but
so we have one reality going forward you
have an exponential number of models
going back right
and those are the high value targets
it's like your second best model your
third best your fourth best
right if your second best model turns
out to be the best one then its weight
goes up as it should
so essentially you know you know this
whole thing that like jan really likes
it like you know
uh you know you have the energy
landscape and you pull down the energy
of the good parts and up the energy of
the bad parts right and that's how you
learn right
the way to do that is to always be
comparing your best models
right and again you can have this can be
done even better than that i'm letting
out because of this exponential aspect
of this and then the the energy you know
of the of the bad parts goes up right
because they they fail to to match the
incoming data this i think is their
right to do things both in terms of
efficiency
and in terms of generalizing better so
it's a win-win and i don't know why
everybody isn't doing it this way so you
must then have some sympathy for um jeff
hawkins kind of thousand brains where
it's like hey these cortical you know
cortical columns are all doing kind of
their own independent little uh model
generation and then and then there's a
voting you know kind of scheme where out
of these thousands of possible worlds
you know they kind of converge on which
ones they think are are most likely
i i use exactly the right words i have
some sympathy for jeff hawking
jeff hawkins um
some
sympathy for his ideas yeah yeah exactly
i i think
so you know like i read on intelligence
i haven't read you know the uh you know
the the the more recent book
because i listen to it and you know it
didn't rise enough in in my priority
list maybe mistakenly so but but i read
on intelligence when it came out
and
i i both liked it in some ways and
didn't like it in others you know and
i've heard him talk and and since and
whatnot and i think i mean i understand
what his stream of mind is
and what i like about what he's doing
is that um
interesting because you know his
background is not in your science he's
actually you know his criticism of the
deep learning folks is very valid is
that like you guys say you're inspired
by the brain but that's bs
right like the point you just raised
we're we're doing feed forward and we've
missed the the 9x feedback yeah and
again if you listen to what jan says
right i think it captures it well which
is we should be inspired by nature but
not too much
which from an engineering point of view
is fine but the thing about engineering
in ai is that it'll only get us to local
optimum
to get to the global optimum i think
what jeff is doing is very honorable and
i wish him great success he actually
spent a lot of time talking to the
neuroscientists
understanding the latest neuroscience
and trying to port it over into ai you
know like more power to him there should
be thousands of people doing that you
know there's more he's not the only one
but we need more having said that
at the end of the day unfortunately what
he managed to capture about what's going
on was very small and there are several
things in his approach that i think are
actually off base having said that
trying to understand what i mean here i
think i think
what i think are some key ideas that
people have neglected the unit of
computation is not the neuron it's the
cortical column very good
you you can't think in terms of the
cortex you have to think in terms of
circuits that look through the cortex
and the thalamus and the hippocampus
you will not figure this out if you
don't do at least both of these things
right and there's a few more like that
so like i'm 100 on board with that now
unfortunately you know this is no big
strike against him because the problem
is hard at the end of the day what he's
been able he hasn't been able to take
these ideas very far
and ironically we know when it comes
down to actually doing things it winds
up what he's doing why does that not
look too different from what people have
been doing in machine learning for a
long time which he also kind of often
unfairly you know um cartoonifies and
says like oh this is all that you do
what does i mean there's a lot of other
people doing so so i agree with that
trust
i wish you know if it made more progress
yeah but i mean i think literally you
know skipping
deep learning right now it is in a local
optimum and i think that is a path to at
least the deeper local labs that's right
just quickly there are a couple of
things i love about jeff hawkins i mean
first of all this idea of strong
multi-modality so all of these cortical
columns are informed by different
sensory motor circuits and that's
wonderful for robustness when you're
getting signals from different sensory
motor circuits and also he overcomes the
binding problem because they are tr you
know these as keith was saying that
they're voting and they're talking in
complete objects not in parts of objects
which is really interesting but um the
thing is though because you keep talking
i mean hawkins is an emergentist you
know he thinks we should go down to the
really low level and all of this magic
stuff will happen on the other side of
the spectrum the symbolists think that
we should model the brain or you know
marvin minsky's conception we should
have a vision model people like
yanderkoon are kind of saying okay well
we're nearly there we need to um
incorporate uh causal you know like if
we had the action chain and the models
could do causal reasoning then that
would robustify things and there's
everything in between the linguists are
saying well you can't have the semantics
of similarity you need to have you know
grounding and you need to have first
order logic and so on so there's a whole
spectrum isn't it
there it is and
i mean you've probably had this
experience like when you talk to the
symbolists they're very very hardcore
about their position that like trying to
look at things at the level is is
ridiculous when you talk to the
emergency the emergencies you also the
bottom up folks versus the top down is
another way to look at this right you
also have people are like very strongly
convinced that this is the way to go
because there's all these things wrong
with doing things at the symbolic level
and and and you know
what i think is that they're all correct
and they are all wrong
it's it's it the thing is that ai is a
very hard problem and this is a lot like
you know the blind man and the elephant
right
it's like
you know to start with with a simplest
approach right this famous thing called
the physical symbol hypothesis that that
you know nolan simon enunciated which is
basically saying
you know you'd or like mars levels right
it's probably more familiar to people
these days is we should do our research
at that level of abstraction ignoring
the implementation
and honestly there is a lot of merit to
that
because you will lose the force for the
trees if you don't keep that perspective
in mind
right and it is mathematically true
that you know any simple system you know
it's tuning machines right
having said that and i think this
kind of what's a little more subtle
unfortunately the symbolists kind of
didn't cut me on to is that
thinking about so that it's not that
hypothesis is incorrect it's correct
and it's not that it's not useful it is
useful because it allows you to abstract
a lot of details but it leads you in the
wrong direction
it leads in the wrong direction because
for example we're just talking about
energy and if you really look at how the
brain works the energy constraint is
such a powerful force acting on
everything
but if you do things that the physical
symbol system you don't even talk about
energy so you just missed out on a lot
of really useful constraints preferring
eye intelligence why would you want to
do that why would you want to shoot
yourself in the foot like that right so
that's you know that's then i think is
one one one aspect now when you go
bottom up right
i think and again in contravention to
the physical symbol system hypothesis
these melted soap part of what makes
this problem hard and makes people talk
past each other is that it's not just
that there's like the neural level and
then there's like the you know symbolic
level there's a hundred levels here that
we haven't figured out yet
right
for example going from individual
neurons to cortical columns to the
circuits that you know involve the tail
right we already know what some of these
levels are right so the problem is that
like we have there's all these levels
that we haven't been talking about and
instead of like trying to do this
dichotomy between a and b at the ends of
the spectrum we we got to start
populating this right but having said
all that
and again this is an intuition i can't
prove it to you it's like
what we have computers are very
different from brains in many regards
right in computers we cannot do and
force by design because it's convenient
for us a very strong separation between
the architecture and the operating
system and the applications and whatnot
because otherwise it wouldn't we
wouldn't be able to deal with it but the
brain isn't like that
in the brain you still see a lot of the
flavor of the lowest levels at the
highest ones
which probably has a lot to do with the
fact that the brain evolved and emerged
and wasn't programmed by someone right
so
and again the physical symbolism
causes you to ignore that which again is
a big loss right i think a lot of how we
behave even at the conscious system two
level is directly related to the
substrate like the lowest levels so i
actually do think
you know counter tool are the symbol is
that the lowest levels do have a lot to
teach us about the the highest levels
but yeah right
if i when i have to choose what research
to do right
i'm not super excited about going bottom
up because it's such a long distance to
the goal
you're just going to spend your entire
life on stuff that's going to get you
epsilon closer right i think you need to
like try to see
again i agree with mari their regards
you need to you know understand things
at the computational level
to just have a handle on them right
otherwise they're gonna spin your wheels
forever
apparently um lisa feldman barrett said
that this you know paul mclean's notion
of the triune brain and this idea that
there are old parts of the brain and new
parts of the brain she said that was one
of the biggest myths in in all of
science uh because of course they've
co-evolved together but um we were just
talking about um you know lacoon's
assertion about i mean everyone says
cause or representation learning is is
going to be brilliant actually benjo
talks about it as well there are loads
of folks actually trying to learn the um
the causal structure from observational
data uh what's your take just on on that
whole thing
i think causality is a very problematic
word
right every time i hear the word causal
particularly coming from deep learning
it's one thing to hear the word caused
coming from to the pearl right i know
what that means exactly and what the ins
and outs are maybe the pros and the cons
but that is a very you know well worked
out notion of causality
when i hear the word causal coming from
deep learning people i start to get
nervous
because i think a lot of what people are
calling causal is
i mean it's another one of those words
right
uh i think you could say this is not a
this is not quite what i think but it's
a good reference point that causality is
another one of those useful illusions
space you can prime my useful illusions
free will is a useful illusion because l
is another one of those useful illusions
right
what what is causality real right and
then it's also you know like it's
another one was like context now we're
missing context like one of those magic
words of like everything that you're
learning system can't do right you just
you know sprinkle this causal pixie dust
on it and then suddenly everything is
brilliant right it ain't gonna work out
right
it's not it's not gonna work like that
right so so what do we so
let's start maybe the the best you know
way to this like start from like we have
these learning engines that are great at
discovering correlations right they
could be even better but let's just take
that as a given like we're very good at
discovering correlations right now what
is missing right first of all is
something missing i do think that
something is missing right but what is
it that's missing right
what's missing is that
the goal
of learning
is not just to predict accurately this
is how you evaluate a learning algorithm
is this predictive accuracy you know
like this this is amazing this is the
methodologies god is very fast but you
have to realize that predicted
prediction is not the end goal
prediction is subservient to action
the whole point of learning and
predicting and the the generative model
and all of that is to guide your action
right and in order to guide my ac and
this in your brain and in any ai system
any enforcement line system at the end
of the day the point is you want to take
the best actions that will maximize your
reward your fitness whatever right and
predictions are not enough to take
actions
i have predictions obtained by observing
the world
right
you have to be able to predict
the results of your own actions
this is what causality is
right causality is being able to predict
the effects of your actions even if you
haven't taken them before that's the key
if i've take connections before and
gather that i can learn their effects by
purely correlational learning and then i
don't need causal anything but of course
most of the time in both nature and
society and technology it's like you've
got to consider the space of actions and
then you know
the larger the space the worse the
problem gets right
you know you have more power but you
also have a bigger problem it's like you
have to be able to predict the effects
of actions and sequences of actions in
particular like sequences of moves and
again that you've never taken before
right and now this is a very different
ball of wax you can't just do that by
correlation right another question is
like how do you learn that
right and the way i look at you know
things like all of these theories of
causality right maybe it's a very
machine learning way to look is like
these are inductive biases a theory of
causality is an invective bias
that lets you generalize from the
results of actions that you have taken
to the results of actions that you have
not taken
right this is all that causalization and
by the way there are formal theories
that work like this like you know like
phil david for example in a well-known
vision statistician right who's called
you know with with with uh with who they
in the past right he says we don't need
any of this all you like statisticians
are very resistant to causality partly
for historical reasons partly for bad
reasons which you know who they will
tell you about but but i think
partly at least from the bayesian
statisticians point of view
i understand the resistance because it's
like this if i have decision theory
right
right you know my decisions are part of
my space right and now what i'm doing is
like i'm conditioning on my actions
right
i condition on the world's behavior i
learn my action i predict the result
right that's why reinforcement learners
do and if you can do that well you don't
need to talk about causal you know i
think you do need to talk or it's
advantageous convenient you know again
it's useful to talk about gazelle
because you do want to focus on this
problem of predicting the effects of
actions that you haven't taken but this
is really all that causality is it's not
some
magic
thing that like you know that that that
solves all problems and and i think
right
so it's important to do causal learning
in this sense but i also think it's
important also important to not lose our
way doing all sorts of things that
aren't going to solve the problem
because you know this is the problem
that you have to solve
i often times think about causality in
the context of this inherent asymmetry
between um
between both the past and the future and
knowledge and control and and i love
this quote
from shannon which i heard many years
ago and it's really what set me off on
this on this line of thinking which is
he said um
we have knowledge of the past but cannot
control it
we can control the future but we have no
knowledge of it
yeah in fact um i sympathize with that
thought so much that you know like
there's this debate about what is time
right like physicists for example are
very much into this and usually they
were not saying whoa it's you know it's
entropy increasing and whatnot which
which i find very unsatisfying i
actually think it's actually closer to
the truth of life why do we have this
notion of time right it's like this is
the real distinction between the past
and the future is between control and
prediction right it's like if you take
everything right and separate into the
stuff that we know very well but can't
control the stuff that we can't control
right if you think about like convergent
and diverging processes when there's a
divergent process is when we have the
opportunity of control that's why those
things are in the future right so i
actually think there's you know
we're not we're we're not we're not
there yet but but i think there's a lot
um
there's a lot of promise in thinking
about things that way we were looking at
your twitter earlier uh you said if
information is conserved and the
universe is finite it's also cyclical
and entropy the entropy law is false
before you respond to explain that
though i'm curious
those tweets do you just you're just
kind of sitting around and you go you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna throw out
a tweet about uh entropy and its
implications on the universe or did it
did it come from what was the context
that generated that tweet i'm curious no
i'm ready to ask that question because i
think some people have the wrong
model of of what i tweet and why
i don't throw stuff out that that just
occurred to me
number one
i don't i don't throw stuff out just to
be provocative or to you know to say
whatever right the things that are tweet
that i tweet are either things that i
believe in
could be wrong
or hypothesis that i think are plausible
and deserve consideration
and usually behind every one of these
tweets there's actually a lot of thought
and you know we quickly do a couple of
examples so you're like and usually you
know and then some people if people
follow up you know then i then i then i
will often elaborate a little bit right
but like any one of these tweets like
you know i mean like i could write the
whole article about it except you know
there's no time so what's the category
on this one i'm really curious what um
what the greater purpose was
well so
the grid
i didn't say that there was a greater
purpose you know
maybe the [ __ ] i mean there is a greater
purpose but like i think when you're
doing research right you think about
things and you follow your instinct
about like this is interesting because
it might have important consequences you
might not know exactly what they are
right i mean there's some things that
you do with a very concrete action
purpose at the time but you know
thinking about you know the nature of
space-time is not one of those although
eventually that might even have bigger
consequences than anything else but like
what is behind the tweet like this one
about entropy right is is is um
i think
that people
have
physicists
have confused themselves about the
entropy law
for you know almost 200 years now
right and and we are all confused along
with them
right
and and this confusion is actually
holding us back
right
and and what is the confusion right i
mean we could go into more details about
what you know the things that people
have written about this going back to
boltzmann and gibbs and whatnot right
but but let me give you a modern ai take
on this which is what's behind that
tweet right and then you know i i had
other tweets related to this saying some
of these things but
here's
let me let me tell you the second law
without mentioning the word entropy
which i think is incredibly like right
the universe is a markov chain
with a very very large state space
evolves step by step
and very importantly it's a symmetric
markov chain
it's a symmetric minecraft chain mean
like the probability of transitioning
from a to b
is equal to the probability of
transitioning from b to a for n to
states a and b
right i mean this is the basic fact
right like of newtonian mechanics and
you know and and quantum you know
hamiltonian unitary evolution etcetera
etcetera is that things are reversible
right like my probability of going from
once you're not i have i'm just as
likely to go from this state to that
state as vice versa right
this is the confusion with entropy is
that then but then microscopically this
is not what you observe right but this
is like if we believe in the laws of
physics as we understand them right now
which we could you know go into but
let's not right now right then
then these probabilities are symmetric
right so the universe is a markov so so
to summarize the universe is a symmetric
markov chain right
therefore
this is like a basic piece of math right
that's like you know completely trivial
stats 101 it converges to the uniform
distribution period
i mean not period there's various
conditions of irreducibility and blah
blah blah but again setting those
technicalities you know
there's some stuff there but ignoring
that which is not relevant to this
discussion if you're if you're um
if you are a symmetric markov chain you
converge to the uniform distribution
because in detailed balance right the
probability of being in the states a
times the probability of transitioning
it from a to b has to be the same as the
reverse right if the transition
probabilities are the same their detail
balance can only be satisfied if the
probabilities are the same as well it is
just mathematical right it's like you
know
there's nothing complicated about it
but what this means i mean think about
it so
if the universe is asymmetric markov
chain and we have very good reason to
believe it is right then it's going to
converge to the uniform distribution
right okay this is a cosmic statement
and entropy is just a measure of how
close you are to the uniform
distribution nothing else
right entropy is increasing gp is
increasing sure you can thread things
that way but they framed it that way
because they didn't know about markov
chains back then they were invented by
andy markov in 1913 long after all of
this
if people had been studying this back
when they were and then there was this
thing like continuity like people think
in continuous terms but you can do all
this with with you know uh with
continuous um
time as well but let's let's not do that
right so i was going to watch that does
it change anything having a discrete
markov chain to represent states in the
universe
i mean of course it doesn't because the
universe is not continuous right
continuity is just a convenient
approximation to a discrete reality
again people are so confused about this
right like again
you know
i've i talked with many people about
this you know physicists and
non-physicists and and and people have i
mean
i mean i think to be sure it's an open
question it's it's not known whether
it's continuous or some underlying you
know lattice or discrete thing right i
mean fair enough and by the way this
gets back to so
before we continue this just to close
the previous point right if the universe
is discrete
right
then there's only a finite number of
states that it can cycle through
right well and just what it's going to
repeat so to answer tim to answer a
question directly if if it is continuous
and you're dealing with continuous
variables what happens is you generalize
to you can you'll get arbitrarily close
to any particular state
you know given enough time so there's
like this little
c or whatever so you'll cycle back like
arbitrarily close
to um to any state
right but that's precisely what never
happens and now you say that whether the
universe is continuous or discreet is an
open question well in science you know
all questions are always open right but
let us what i meant by that is there are
people on both sides of that equation
that are adamant
absolutely and i've adamant that the
universe is discreet and let me tell you
what right i did not come to this
conclusion casually right and i could be
wrong right like i can change my mind
tomorrow right now you should prove me
wrong right so like but but but she's i
think was the way to think about this
like with scientists
let us set aside all of that continuous
math that you know we've had since
newton and that quantum mechanics is
also full what now like
math is models models are convenient and
by the way i'm not against continuity
infinitesimation again they're
incredibly convenient like i use them
all the time so i'm not against that but
if you want to get the fundamentals
right you got to look at observations
right
no one has ever or will ever make an
observation of something infinitesimal
or infinite
because earnings assuming infinite is
this is is impossible right so let's you
know
let's say that i want to substitute a
second infinitesimal is a more
interesting question right like has
anyone ever measured an infinitesimal
small quantity no of course not because
you know things are quantized
right here's anybody and that that
people accept right it's like there's
the two-slit experiment and things like
that and you know like and you see those
things one at a time right and then i
mean i've actually done this like you
have to go through and look at like all
these observations that people make in
particle detectors with geiger counters
with like this that and the other i like
you know like with photo detectors your
eye your retina rhodopsin is this
protein that detects light what do they
do they all do the same thing they
undergo a discrete state change there is
no continuity there
what does an atomic clock do right and
then people accept this first you know
quantities like i'm like oh but space
and time you don't know if they're
continuously like have you measured the
continuous infinitesimal piece of space
or time right let's think of time for
just a second like an atomic clock right
is an atom flipping discretely back and
forth between two states this quickly so
let me let me agree we cannot measure a
period of time that is short there's
like nothing happening between those so
at the most basic level space time and
all quantities are the scripts like so
how can anybody believe otherwise well
let me agree with you on
on
that point let's posit that every
observation ever made you know as is of
finite precision it's discrete you know
these quantum events that occur
but here's the kind of remarkable thing
at least the remarkable thing to a lot
of folks including myself
is that
get that part however those observations
are described
so well by these smooth continuous
models and so then you get to this kind
of deeper philosophical question are are
they antic you know are they real is
there something actually real content
and i really like your take on that
which is you know how do we know that
we're not just sitting on top of this
ontic this real underlying smooth thing
but all we're ever observing are
discrete you know uh aspects of it
yes i mean so and indeed i think the the
more informed people that is the
argument that they will make right they
will accept that all our measurements
are discrete right but now here's the
thing like
what you're saying is an illusion
it's like the illusion that people had
that there were no fractals
the the challenge i would have there is
the way in which it's not illusory is we
don't actually have any
discreetly defined mathematics that can
reproduce the predictions of these
continuous mathematics
very good right so you just sit on the
crucial point right now but before we go
to that let me mention another thing
which is renormalization
right
so the beauty of continuous math right
that goes back to newton and this is
amazing right this is like one of the
most amazing things ever he's like he
posited these laws based on extremely
low precision data
and then they were valid to 10 more
orders of magnitude this is
mind-boggling right and that's why we
believe in continuous anything right
this is extraordinary who could have
predicted that right it boggles the mind
right
but it has reached its limits
quantum field theory is being leveled by
these infinities that you get by trying
to sum over continuous but trying to
integrate over continuous things like
why do the path integrals keep diverging
why do they need all these hacks it's
like something is going deeply deeply
wrong there right we've reached the
limit so why wouldn't we right i mean
come on right would that do you really
think they would go on
foreign scale right measuring something
more finely requires so much energy that
it creates a black hole so the
information doesn't get out so yeah sure
one way or another that is dead but
to answer the really important part
right
i mean feynman famously said right and
fighting was the guy who created all of
this path integral stuff and whatnot
right and and and he said like i get all
these letters by people saying like oh
but like you know his space really
continuous and you know all those
complicated appetizers you need them and
his answer which is completely
right is like give me a better option
it's not that he believes deeply that
space is continuous it's that
you know
the other options that we have to not
work as well and that is their reason
right but i think we and and you know
i'm all for that right you know we
should use those things because it's all
we have but we shouldn't start to
confuse them for fundamentals and
moreover i mean it's interesting because
in the history of quantum mechanics once
people discover this there was the
people who were like i mean there were
the statements by like you know i think
schrodinger said like continuity is just
like this horrendous monstrous notion
like who could possibly believe such a
thing right and and i agree but then
they they got stuck right
and we have to respect the fact that
they got stuck right they really bumped
into real difficulties so you were right
that continuous math in a way is an
amazingly powerful tool
but we shouldn't give up
on doing better and i'm not giving up on
doing better and you know i'm curious on
how you might do better yeah yeah i was
about to ask that which is do you have a
favorite do you have a favorite uh
discretized
direct or let's say favorite direction
that people are trying to pursue for for
discretized you know theories of
everything is there is there one that
stands out to you as the most promising
no i mean of course so um if you look at
the state of physics today right there's
the string theorists who in my view are
like you know going completely in the
wrong direction you know sorry and then
there's the loop quantum gravity folks
who have the right idea
right okay and they you know likely i
mean
even the string theorists these days you
know after you know 20 years of hard
locks or 30
pretty much everybody at this point
believes that yeah space-time is going
to be discrete in some way
the question is how right
but th but the but the i mean and if you
come at this from like a computer
scientist's point of view you i you know
like
string theory is physics for electrical
engineers i love quantum gravity is
physics for computer scientists it's
like space is a graph
there's relations there's notes and i'm
like you know what's not to like about
that right so is this kind of like the
hyper graph models of of wolfram or so
his own version right it's it's uh it's
i mean wilfred is one guy right we could
talk about what he's been doing which is
interesting and also has its problems
but you know loop quantum graph right so
there's this whole approach to that goes
back to you know to john wheeler and you
know like it's many decades older like
it's try to quantize gravity
right
and when you quantize gravity inherently
you qualify space time because space
time is gravity right that's that's what
general relativity tells us right so
they have been trying to quantize
space-time you know for decades
and and i agree with the general thing
that they know they have very
complicated schemes to do this over
complicated unfortunately but again
and then they would not bring it back
these continuous elements and so even
though i sympathize with that direction
in general they've also gotten stuck
and i don't think they have the answer
no i think there's an answer to be
hacked that no one has had yet and it
may be coming you know like you know
this may happen tomorrow and it'll be
when one of the greatest you know
revolutions and it'll be like quantum
mechanics in the 20th century so it's
coming well i'll tell you a funny
comment i heard um by uh roger penrose
which was somebody was asking him about
um luke quantum gravity and he said i
think they've they've kind of gotten it
backwards instead of trying to quantize
gravity we should be trying to figure
out how to gravitize quantum mechanics
so i i don't know
i'm not sure which side of that coin i
come down but it's an interesting thing
that's a very logic pinwheels thing to
say because of course he's a you know
you always understand people buying this
by in machine learning or physics or
anything like what what is deep down in
them what is the theory that they really
that really resonates with them and for
him it's general relativity he's a
minority among physicists to him
nothing exceeds the beauty and the power
of general relativity and quantum
mechanics is like this ugly pile of
hacks which it is but it works sounds
more important but but actually but my
answer to that is that neither
i don't think you need to reduce gravity
to quantum mechanics or quantum kinds to
gravity that both both are those you
know paths into a wall what you need to
do is to reduce both to something deeper
and in fact i think it's all it all goes
back to newton it's all little's fault
right he gave us a lot but he also got
us into the things that like
relativity is is a departure from from
newtonian physics in one way quantum
mechanic is a departure from return to
physics in another
right
but the problem is that there are a lot
of things about the autonomous physics
that are still wrong
in eutonic physics and have been
inherited by gravity and quantum
mechanics in particular what space-time
is
and this is where i think we need to
solve the problems like we actually need
to go back to newton and overturn some
of what he did to be able to reconcile
you know uh quantum hunger and for
example right um what is time right
there's this guy julian barber that has
a theory of time that that that that to
me is really perceptive and what he did
was like really go and and again if you
look at these things from machine
learning point of view it's quite
fascinating it's like i'm going to put
this in a way that he never would
there's like time is a latent variable
that we have induced
to relate the things that we do observe
exactly and so is space
and so our fields and so our light these
are all latent variables
and what we need is a better set of
latent variables what we need is a
better set of business functions right
this is something like oh is it
particles is it waves no those are both
bad basis functions we need a different
beta set of basis functions so i think
we need to reduce space and time to
something deeper and that's when all of
this will come together
fantastic well professor pedro dominguez
it's been an absolute honor to have you
on the show thank you so much for
joining us
thanks for having me